Google Cloud updates what's that you
want to learn something well you're in
luck because we have brand new
generative AI training options whether
you're technical Tech adjacent or
something else entirely we've got
something for you including a no cost
introductory level course that only
takes about 45 minutes from start to
finish and we're constantly adding to
our catalog of training on Google Cloud
skills boost so go check it out
to defend against threats a modern
security operations platform needs to be
infused with a deep understanding of
those threats and possess the ability to
apply intelligence to each customer's
unique environment we've recently added
even more to Chronicle security
operations enabling secops teams to
become even more proactive learn more
about our new applied threat
Intelligence on the blog and we'll see
you on next week's